what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course
spider-man no way home i know a lot of
people are getting really
impatient for that spider-man no way
home trailer myself included
in fact i put out a tweet the other day
asking if at this point we even really
need the spider-man no way home trailer
of course i think we do but i was just
curious to hear what everybody else
thought
and i see everybody's frustration but
hopefully today's news will
put that at ease a tiny bit and you're
either going to enjoy this news
or kind of think that sony is trolling a
little bit more but i promise you
today's news
is a good thing and to keep up to date
on the spider-man news be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
alright so if you haven't heard sony
pictures
is attending cinemacon this year and if
you have heard this news you may not
have heard
everything that's going along with it so
stick with me here so
sony pictures is actually opening up
cinemacon on opening night
this is going to take place on august
23rd so in a couple of weeks from now
and it starts at 9 00 pm eastern time
now
sony has three hours they have a
three-hour presentation where they're
said to show
all of their upcoming films not the
whole films obviously but parts or clips
or whatever they want to put together to
show the audience at cinemacon
they have three hours to do this and
spider-man no way home
is definitely going to be a part of it
most likely the very last thing that
they see
this is actually kind of classic sony
they actually did this for spider-man
far from home
before the trailer 4 far from home came
out at cc xp
tom holland and jake gyllenhaal attended
and they showed the actual trailer there
before it came out to the public
they literally showed it at a comic con
ccxp stands for the comic con
experience sony showed it at their panel
before anybody in the world saw it and
unfortunately
but also kind of fortunately it looks
like that's what we're about to see
they're either going to show an actual
trailer or footage
however unfortunately this is probably
not going to be released to the public
it's going to be up to somebody to leak
it if the public is going to see it
it's already been confirmed that no
types of recording devices
at all are going to be allowed inside of
the session and all phones are going to
have to be turned off
and i actually really wouldn't be
surprised if they made them do more like
put their phones in lockers or something
like
that and again do not expect this
footage to go
public at the same time this isn't going
to be like marvel studios showing
something and then at the same time it
pops up on youtube
unfortunately disney has already
confirmed that sony is the one
handling all of the trailer releases and
the marketing disney is in the loop and
aware of everything that they're going
to do and when they're going to do it
but sony is handling everything it's up
to them and this was confirmed by
disney's president of marketing
however there is some good news to this
because even though people can't show
footage
they can still talk about what they saw
even though they're forcing their
cameras off and turning cell phones off
you can't stop people
hundreds of people from going out and
talking about what they saw
and of course there are probably going
to be some very loyal spider-man fans
out there who probably can't wait to go
to the internet and share what they saw
so despite what happens if any type of
footage
is shown for spider-man no way home we
are going to hear about that footage and
know what it is
on august 23rd i almost hope it actually
is
footage and not the actual trailer and
here's why i've said this at kind of the
end of some of my videos and i know the
majority of people don't watch all the
way till the end so i'll say it now in
the middle
i have personally heard from one of my
sources that the very first teaser
trailer
for spider-man no way home is not going
to contain the other spider-man
i was specifically told that when the
marketing campaigns
do start for spider-man no way home they
aren't going to start marketing the
other two spider-man until about either
halfway or two-thirds into the campaign
that means the teaser trailer is not
going to have them and that means
probably the first trailer that we get
isn't going to have them either
however i am specifically talking about
the other two spider-man so that doesn't
mean that we can't see
alfred molina's doggock show up it
doesn't mean that we won't see jamie
foxx's electro
i definitely think we'll see signs of
the multiverse
spider-verse but they're still going to
try and build up hype and the way you do
that is you start with a teaser
tease a little bit then do a full-on
trailer kind of explaining what the
story is and then
you reveal the other two and i still
debate in my mind on whether or not they
should even show the other two before
the movie comes out
i guess it's irrelevant because the very
first day the movie comes out
everybody's going to be talking about it
and everybody's going to know
so i guess if you're sony you just beat
them to it and show it in the trailer
now in terms of when are we actually
going to see the trailer
the general public when is it going to
go on youtube or on tv
we don't really have an exact time frame
right now but daniel rpk at one point in
time said that we would have to have
another shanxi trailer and another
eternals trailer before getting
spider-man well
we've had that other shang-chi trailer
and the other day he actually tweeted
out stating that he thinks that it will
be
with either shangqi or venom 2. and
venom 2 actually makes a lot of sense
because again that is coming from sony
and it actually
seems like right now sony's marketing
priority
is venom 2 which makes sense because it
is coming out first
and they just released their full
trailer for the movie
last week actually not even it was only
five days ago it was this week which
means the full
trailer released literally less than two
months before the movie is actually
coming out which means they released the
teaser trailer
four months before the actual movie is
coming out so we can assume that they're
going to follow somewhat of a similar
pattern for spider-man no way home
now of course like some rumors have been
going around there is
always the possibility that they could
delay spider-man no way home they could
delay its release date
obviously nobody wants this but with all
the different variants of kobid
and yes i did use variant intentionally
there it seems like studios are kind of
freaking out again that people won't go
to theaters
because venom and spiderman no way home
aren't going to be released anywhere
else but in the theaters
these are theatrical releases only so
there is that possibility
that spider-man no way home could be
delayed especially if you consider the
fact that they're actually doing
reshoots right now for the film
now i hope it's not i really hope it's
not but if they did
show a trailer at cinemacon they could
actually reveal
a new release date so keep that in mind
and be prepared for that because that
could happen
but again keep in mind overall good news
because whatever they show
at cinemacon we are going to hear about
we are going to get a
full description of so even though i am
100 convinced that the public is not
going to see whatever footage or trailer
for spider-man no way home that is going
to be shown at cinemacon
i am convinced that we will be getting
an exact description of what they saw
because this happened with spider-man
far from home
sony showed the trailer the actual
trailer before the public saw it and
then everybody knew what it was
we didn't see it but we had a very
accurate description
and side note marvel is also going to be
there and they've actually done this
before too before we got any footage for
the eternals they showed it at ccxp
and apparently they're actually going to
be showing a full screening of
shanghi somewhere at cinemacon so marvel
is going to be there and have a presence
as well which
is good news because that means the
likelihood of sony showing spider-man no
way home footage is very
very high and who knows if marvel
studios does do their own panel we could
get a description for shang qi
the eternals miss marvel hawkeye moon
knight
all of their upcoming stuff we could
learn a great deal more about
but of course i know that everybody at
this point is pretty much just concerned
about that spider-man no way home
trailer which i completely
understand hopefully this means that the
actual trailer will come out not too
long after the footage is shown at
cinemacon
but keep an eye out the 23rd for more
information about whatever they show
at cinemacon because we are going to
find out then so
be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the videos and you can follow
me on twitter and
instagram because i always do live
updates on there let me know your
thoughts on the video
in the comment down below don't forget
to like the video and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof